shoppers looking to score cyber monday
deals are expected to spend a record
nine point four billion dollars online
today and that comes after Black
Friday's record-setting seven point four
billion dollars in cyber sales all of
those online purchases have led to a
surge in deliveries leaving cities
across the country dealing with millions
of packages the Los Angeles Chicago and
New York areas received the most
deliveries last year in New York that
was about 3.6 million packages every
single day malenky is at a UPS store
here in New York MOA good morning I'm
guessing there's a downside all those
deliveries online shopping accounts for
roughly 10% of retail purchases today
and companies are working hard to make
these deliveries of these packages
faster than ever all these are set to be
shipped down today but with the changing
delivery landscape there are still some
growing pains how many packages will
Amazon deliver this year at least three
billion and they have company
FedEx plans to haul more than 33 million
packages today on Cyber Monday UPS
expects to move more than 32 million
goods a day between Thanksgiving and
Christmas we like to think of ourselves
as a sort of Santa's workshop here this
time of year
Dave Clark Amazon senior VP of worldwide
operations says that workshop is
cranking out packages faster than ever
we've delivered billions of packages
already in one day to customers why one
day it's two days not good enough well
no customer is ever gonna say please
deliver that to me slower to meet
delivery demands Amazon is increasing
their deployment this holiday season
with about 50,000 delivery vehicles it's
really about how close can I get the
inventory you a one-hour delivery is one
hour because it's very very close to you
you know in a small forward deployed
fulfillment center of it but that demand
can lead to overrun mail rooms packages
spilling out onto city streets and
Goodchild the director of supply chain
transport and logistics at the
University of Washington says the
delivery side of e-commerce is a work in
progress so we want public space to be
used as like a temporary distribution
center I don't think we do with your
stories about mail rooms that are just
sort of flooding with package
these changes are happening so quickly
that sometimes buildings and the
vehicles are catching up to the changes
that are happening on the consumer side
Clark insists the current delivery model
means fewer vehicles on the roads
what you're seeing is one delivery van
packed full of packages instead of a
hundred or 200 or 300 cars on the road
with a customer going to a store coming
back with one package good child agrees
delivery services have the potential to
be kind of like a big shared vehicle
that does better than the status quo to
an extent the faster you make that
request the harder it is for that
delivery company to be efficient the
total impact has a lot to do with the
details of or how quickly did you have
it delivered and where did it come from
well with the increased delivery demands
to deliver all of these packages at UPS
Amazon and FedEx all tell us that they
are trying to reduce their carbon
footprint by introducing eco-friendly
vehicles to their delivery fleet here at
UPS Gale they tell us they've introduced
about 10,000 vehicles to their fleet
well we like eco-friendly thank you very
much mola